welcome back to New rockstars I'm
Whitney van leningham and now that we
finally have a release date and trailer
for Indiana Jones 5. I decided to start
a little rewatch of the original trilogy
today I'm taking you frame by frame
through Raiders of the Lost Ark and
breaking down all the details you might
have missed in the very first Indiana
Jones George Lucas first conceived his
idea for Indiana Jones in 1971. shortly
after the release of his second film
American Graffiti and before he began
working on Star Wars inspired by serials
from the 1930s and 40s like Buck Rogers
Zorro's fighting Legion spymaster and
others Lucas wanted to tell the tale of
an archaeologist traveling the globe in
search of a rare artifact he originally
named the character Indiana Smith
Indiana being the name of his Alaskan
Malamute dog who also inspired Chewbacca
and Smith named for Steve McQueen's
character in Nevada Smith in 1975 Lucas
floated the idea past writer and
director Philip Kaufman who suggested
that Indy's Quest be in search of the
Lost Ark of the Covenant Kaufman
actually first heard the story of the
Ark from his childhood dentist and
decided that it would be the perfect
McGuffin for this film The Ark of the
Covenant was the chess that the Hebrews
used to carry God's ten commandments it
was believed to hold special powers and
Legend has it that any army that carries
it is Invincible one biblical story
tells the tale of the Battle of Jericho
where the voice of God spoke to the
Hebrews instructing them to march the
ark around the city's walls three times
when they blew their horns the walls of
Jericho collapsed giving the Hebrews the
opportunity to attack Lucas said his
idea for this project to decide for
several years until after Star Wars
premiered in 1977 after the film's
release Lucas was terrified that his
Space Opera would be a gigantic flop so
he headed to Hawaii to lay low there he
spent time with Steven Spielberg who was
also recuperating after his movie Close
Encounters of the Third Kind on the
islands when Spielberg told Lucas that
he wanted to work on a James Bond movie
Next Lucas had a better idea in mind
Spielberg suggested that Lucas hire
brand new screenwriter Lawrence Caston
for the script and in 1978 the three men
outlined the story of Raiders of the
Lost Ark Spielberg was actually the one
to suggest that they changed the
character's name from Indiana Smith to
Indiana Jones because he was afraid it
would sound too similar to Nevada Smith
pre-production for the movie began in
December of 1989. interestingly however
Harrison Ford wasn't Lucas's First
Choice to play Indie he wanted to cast
an unknown actor for a part and
considered Bill Murray Nick Nolte Steve
Martin Chevy Chase Tim Matheson Nick
Mancuso Peter Coyote Jack Nicholson Jeff
Bridges John Shea Sam Elliott and Harry
Hamlin for the principal role Tom
Selleck ended up being Lucas's ideal
casting for Jones but after CBS realized
what a hot commodity the actor was the
greenlit celex show Magnum PI which
forced him to drop from Raiders luckily
Spielberg loved Ford's performance as
Han Solo so much that he insisted on
approaching him although Lucas didn't
think that Ford would be game in the
beginning Indiana Jones ultimately
turned out to be one of his all-time
favorite characters as we all know Ford
eventually got a little sick of a Han
Solo hype and I of course want nothing
to do with it but his love for Indiana
Jones has remained he chose to play the
character as an academic first in an
adventurous second which was ultimately
the best possible choice for Indie my
favorite almost casting for this movie
however was Solace part initially the
production team wanted Danny DeVito to
play John Reese Davis's excavator for
the role of Marion Ravenwood whose name
was inspired by caston's grandmother and
the Los Angeles street named Ravenwood
Court Lucas wanted to cast a leading
lady that would be an equal to her male
counterparts inspired by actresses
Barbara Stanwick Irene Dunn and Ann
Sheridan who starred in movies in the
1920s Spielberg was extremely impressed
with Karen Allen's role as an
independent female character in Animal
House and sought her for the role during
the audition process one of the first
questions he asked her was how well do
you spit hoping to convey Marion's
toughness on screen Indiana Jones Is Now
classic attire a leather jacket and
khaki pants was inspired by Humphrey
Bogart's character in The Treasure of
Sierra Madre as well as Charlton Heston
in secrets of the Incas costume designer
Deborah nanduelandis dumped about box of
hats on the floor one day and asked
Harrison Ford to pick one the Hat they
chose allowed them to create indie's
recognizable silhouette and fun fact
Raiders is actually the only one of
these movies where Indy doesn't lose his
hats both Lucas and Spielberg wanted to
emulate the heroes of their favorite
1940s serial movies by making sure the
hats stayed on because I don't know
having your hat not fall off your head
is somehow more manly
all right enough production talk now
it's time to jump into the Nazi punching
action the Peruvian opening of Raiders
was actually shot in Hawaii and the
mountain that the Paramount Picture logo
dissolves into is kalalaya Mountain on
the island of Kauai Spielberg chose to
fade the logo into the surroundings as
an homage to the films he made in
childhood which featured a similarly
edited introduction he also chose the
1940s version of Paramount's logo to
make this intro feel more authentic for
the time period instead of just using
the updated 1980s logo in 1936 Indiana
Jones and his guides are traipsing
through the Peruvian jungle in search of
a golden idol that Jones desperately
wants to put in a museum Dr Jones is in
a race to find the golden idol against
his rival history dork Renee belock who
since grad school has been scooping all
of Indy's finds if Indy's companion
santifa looks familiar that's because
it's Doc Ock himself Raiders of the Lost
Ark was Alfred Molina's film debut and
certainly one of his most iconic roles
of all time during the scene where Indy
has to sweep a clutter of tarantulas off
santipo's back the production crew had a
hard time getting them to scatter off in
order to get the shot they placed a
female tarantula on Molina's chest to
provoke the males to move Indy's other
guide Barranca who later ends up dead is
one of two characters played by Vic
Taliban and Raiders after his death at
the hands of the hovitos tablian changes
costumes and becomes the monkey man in
Cairo although his monkey dies which
we'll talk about later this second
character didn't get any on-screen
closure he simply vanishes oddly enough
the temple scenes booby traps were
inspired by Scrooge McDuck in 1954 comic
issue number seven of Uncle Scrooge
featured a comic strip titled the Seven
Cities of Cibola in which the Beagle
boys remove a mystical Idol from a
pedestal only to be chased by a boulder
just like in Raiders Andy and santipo
encounter a number of these types of
booby traps including a light sensitive
Spike trap a never-ending pit a wall
that shoots darts if you step on the
wrong floor tile and a collapsing layer
triggered by the removal of the idol
when the spikes are triggered Indy comes
face to face with the corpse of rival
archaeologist Dr Forrestal who went
missing on his search for the idol after
success successfully swinging across the
giant hole in the floor we kept a
glimpse of the Sunburst the MacGuffin
from another film that inspired Raiders
called secrets of the Incas this 1954
movie starred Charlton Heston and has a
number of similarities to Indy its
protagonist Harry Steele is a seedy
American tour guide living in Peru where
India is currently adventuring Steel's
ultimate goal is to find the
aforementioned Sunburst an ancient
treasure with the power to return the
Incan Empire to its former glory while I
wouldn't call Dr Henry Jones Jr's CD I
would say that he's a hot Professor
Moonlighting is a grave robber which
isn't exactly an entirely Noble
profession satipo betrays Jones after
finding the idol his mechanical eyes
were created to appear as though they
followed Indy around the room like a
creepy Scooby-Doo painting this
fertility Idol was also inspired by an
Aztec sculpture of a goddess giving
birth as the temple collapses Indy flees
the wreckage in Hot Pursuit Of The
Traitor satipo who he finds impaled on
some spikes with the idol at his feet
but although he manages to outrun
poisonous darts in that gigantic goddamn
Boulder he's caught by the jovito's
tribes healing their fertility Idol
suddenly another of Indy's archeology
Rivals steps over barranca's corpse and
takes the idol from him this is Renee
Bellic and this isn't the first time
he's scooped a find right out from under
Indy's nose played by Paul Freeman
Bellic worked in cahoots with the Nazis
to loot and steal from various native
cultures Jones manages to outrun the
havitos scrambling aboard a waiting sea
plane flown by his pilot friend jock and
Jock's cockpit buddy Reggie the snake on
the side of the plane you can see the
numbers and letters ob-cpo and homage to
both Obi-Wan Kenobi and C-3PO from Star
Wars as they take flight the sound of
the plane's engine starting is the same
sound the Millennium Falcon makes when
its hyperdrive fails
[Music]
John Williams reader's March also plays
in this scene for the first time
during filming This Plane actually
crashed from a height of 20 feet on the
first take Harrison Ford's leg was
dangling too close to the air flap which
caused the accident actually Ford did
most of his own stunts on this film so
he got injured a lot but thankfully this
wasn't one of those times as 2022 draws
to a close everybody's looking at the
stuff they put off all year going I
should do that now while it may not be
possible to write the Great American
novel before 2023 shows up you
absolutely can get a clean professional
looking website up and running quickly
and easily thanks to Squarespace
Squarespace is the all-in-one platform
for building your brand and growing your
business online Squarespace makes it
easy to make an awesome website that
lets you engage with your audience and
sell everything you need your products
content you create and even your time if
you're a social butterfly on social
media you can directly post from any
profile you want on your website and
automatically push website content to
your favorite social media channels so
your followers can share it too
squarespace's analytics tools will help
you learn where your traffic and sales
are coming from so you can improve your
website and build a marketing strategy
based either on your top keywords or
most popular products and content and if
you're into making videos like me
Squarespace can help you create Pro
level videos effortlessly the
Squarespace video studio app helps you
make and share engaging videos to tell
your story grow your audience and drive
sales head to squarespace.com for a free
trial when you're ready to launch go to
squarespace.com new rockstars to save 10
on your first purchase of a website or
domain after his daring Escape Dr Jones
returns to his life as a professor of
archeology teaching a one-on-one class
on the subject at Marshall College
Marshall College is a fictional school
and an homage to Indie producer Frank
Marshall the exterior shots were
actually filmed at the University of the
Pacific in Stockton California and the
interior of the school was filmed
halfway across the globe at the Royal
Masonic School for Girls in
ricksmansworth England when one of his
female students blinks her eyes in this
scene we see that she's written love you
on each eyelid she actually improvised
advise this and now it's one of the most
iconic moments in Raiders Indy's
teachings are interrupted by Dr Marcus
Brody a museum curator and friend of
Jones and his father played by denim
Elliott in exchange for several Museum
pieces found in Peru Jones Bargains with
Marcus for enough money for a ticket to
Marrakesh where he's sure that Bellic
will go to send the golden idol but
Brody has a different proposition he
introduces Indy to two U.S army
Intelligence Officers who questioned him
about the whereabouts of his former
professor at Chicago University Dr Abner
Ravenwood they explained that the Nazis
have been working with archaeologists
all over the globe instructing them to
retrieve various religious artifacts
they also claim that Hitler is obsessed
with the occult namely because of the
occult Legends and beliefs associated
with Nazism including demons witches the
holy grail and other Supernatural items
and entities Indie tells the agents that
he had a falling out with Ravenwood
about 10 years ago although he doesn't
specify what they thought about here it
definitely had something to do with the
fact that 27 year old Jones had some
manner of inappropriate relationship
with ravenwood's 17 year old daughter
Marion the agents read The Intercept to
communicate from the Nazis and Joan
realizes that their message means that
they found the lost city of Tanis and
that they are also in search of the
headpiece of the staff of raw although
Jones claims that no one has been able
to find Tanis for centuries before these
Nazis rediscovery in real life Tannis
was never lost located Northeast of
Cairo Egypt it was first studied in 1798
and was the site of multiple
archaeological excavations in the 19th
century the headpiece of the staff of RA
is a golden medallion rumored to lead
the holder directly to the Ark of the
covenant's location a secret hidden
chamber called The Well of Souls after
disappearing from its last known resting
place the Temple of Solomon in Jerusalem
Legend has it that the Egyptian pharaoh
shishak took the ark with him back to
Tanis in 980 BC Tanis was wiped from the
map by a sandstorm that lasted an entire
year which many suspect was an act of
God's Wrath the Nazis wanted to find the
ark because of its supreme power and
direct connection to God himself because
Dr Ravenwood is the Premier expert on
Tanis and he agrees to find him and the
arc of the Covenant before the Nazis do
when Marcus visits Indy at home he warns
some of the dangers of searching after a
highly sought after ancient and Powerful
artifact and Indie responds Marcus what
are you trying to do scare me you sound
like my mother we've known each other
for a long time I don't believe in magic
a lot of superstitious Hocus Pocus I
don't believe in magic is a line that
Harrison Ford repeats in the dial of
Destiny trailer as Marcus warns Andy
that Marion is the least of his worries
on this journey we hear a few lines from
Marion's theme for the first time
Marion's list of your worries right now
believe me
as Indy takes his seat on the plane to
Nepal and Nazi spies on him from behind
an issue of Life magazine although many
fans initially thought that this
character was taught played by Ronald
Lacy this guy is actually none other
than Raiders special effects artist
Dennis murin at Marion's bar The Raven
our girl goes shot for shot with one of
the biggest dudes in the establishment
without getting too wasted a trick she
mastered with lots of practice when Indy
shows up she punches him in the face for
dating her when she was a teen which is
fair he asks her for the headpiece for
the staff of raw and Marion tells him
that her father his mentor died she
insists he come back tomorrow to talk
about The Medallion claiming that she
doesn't know where it is as soon as he
leaves however Marion reveals that she's
wearing it around her neck for
safekeeping just then Totten some Nazi
buddies show up hoping to steal it for
their own expedition luckily Indy
returns to help her fight the Nazis and
Save The Medallion actor and former pro
wrestler Pat roach is credited as the
giant Sherpa who's lit on fire just
before being shot in the head by Jones
he actually appears again towards the
end of the movie as the ball German
airplane mechanic whose brains get
turned into chunky salsa by the
propeller and is the only actor besides
Harrison Ford who appears in all of the
original trilogy films my favorite small
detail in this fight scene is when one
of the bar's liquor barrels a shot
causing the liquid inside to spurt out
Marion takes a little Swig of liquid
courage before diving back into the
action which is exactly what I would do
if I just saw a guy emulate tot grabs
the nearly molten hot medallion with his
bare hands imprinting one side of its
markings deep in his flesh Marion does
the smart thing and wraps a cloth around
it before saving it from the burning bar
she insists Indie Maker's partner in
this Expedition and the two fly away
from Nepal to Cairo the footage scene
here of the Douglas DC-3 airplane flying
over Asia is actually taken from the
1973 film Lost Horizon the next several
scenes that take place in Egypt were
shot in Tunisia in North Africa where
the temperatures reached over 130
degrees Fahrenheit while filming over
150 crew members contracted amoebic
dysentery from eating local food and one
of the only people who didn't get sick
was Steven's Spielberg who had brought
his own water and packaged food in Cairo
were introduced to excavator Salah and
the adorable monkey who turns out to be
an evil Nazi spy apparently it took the
animal trainer on set over 50 tries
before the monkey finally learned to do
the Nazi salute but he finally succeeded
after being bribed with a grape Salah
tells Indy that his rival Bellic has
been hired by the Nazis to find The Well
of Souls and the Lost Ark and vows to
take him to someone who can help them
decipher the markings on The Medallion a
fight breaks out in the marketplace when
several Nazis attack Indian Marion while
Marion hides in a straw basket Jones
takes down several Nazis including the
infamous sword fighter whose elaborate
wielding techniques are permanently
interrupted by a bullet from Indy's gun
stuntman Terry Richards who played The
Swordsman practiced for weeks for the
scene's intended extended fight scene
between the two characters but because
Harrison Ford was still extremely sick
with dysentery he decided to Simply
shoot his opponent to end the scene
early although Jones tries to save
Marion the basket she was hiding in is
loaded into the back of a truck filled
with explosives when the truck crashes
in and burst into flames and he assumes
that Marion's dead after rescuing him
Salah explains the Bellic and the Nazis
used a one-sided copy of The Medallion
in the map room to locate the spot where
they believed the ark to be hidden and
that some of his excavators had begun
the dig that morning any mom translates
the warning on The Medallion the Ark of
the Covenant is not to be disturbed the
height of the staff of raw is also
inscribed and the art can only be found
using this exact measurement in the map
room the side of The Medallion possessed
by the Nazis translated to six kadams or
72 inches but when you flip it over the
other side instructs you to take away
one kadam from the staff's height to
honor the Hebrew God ecstatic that
Bellic is digging in the wrong place
Salah starts singing I Am the Monarch of
the sea from HMS pinafore a comedy Opera
from 1878. speaking of these Hitler
loving sons of [ __ ] although it
sounds like many of the Nazi characters
in this movie are speaking German the
actors performing The Language were so
terrible at it that native German
speakers actually had to later redub
some dialogue for later DVD and Blu-ray
releases of Raiders after using the
staff at its correct height in the map
room Jones discovers the true location
of the Ark of the Covenant while looking
for a place to lay low he accidentally
stumbles into the tent where Marion is
being held prisoner instead of rescuing
her however he decides to leave her
behind so that they won't tip off the
Nazis to their presence at the dig site
it makes sense but it's a dick move bro
Marion gets Bellic drunk enough that he
Giggles while she brandishes a knife at
him and starts to make her exit but she
stopped by tot on her way out after
greeting her top pulls a device out of
his coat that initially appears to be
some kind of horrific instrument of
torture to marry an umbelic's surprise
it turns out to be a fancy Nazi coat
hanger this exact joke was actually
first used in a cut of Steven
Spielberg's movie 1941. however the
scene with this joke was ultimately
scrapped from the Final Cut of the film
it does appear however in the deleted
scenes on the 1941 DVD meanwhile Indian
solid dig through the night to uncover
The Well of Souls where the Lost Ark of
the Covenant lies although the pit turns
out to be filled with dangerous asps Dr
Jones faces a sphere of snakes in the
name of archaeological Discovery
although The Well of Soul scenes were
filmed on set at LST studios in England
Spielberg insisted on having between 6
000 to 10 000 live snakes delivered to
the set because fake snakes just didn't
look realistic enough for him there were
tons of delays in shooting namely
because there weren't nearly enough
snakes for Spielberg's liking and there
was also a shortage of Anti-Venom to
keep the crew and performers safe
Stanley Kubrick's daughter Vivian
actually reported the production of
Raiders to the Royal Society for the
prevention of cruelty to animals which
also contributed to delays as Salah and
indy lift the stone Atop The Ark of the
Covenant you can see Raider's most
famous Easter egg the little
hieroglyphic drawing of C-3PO and R2D2
from Star Wars despite their Victory
however bellick and Herman Dietrich
discover salah's team of excavators at
the discovery site once again balik and
his Nazi buddies get the drop on Indy
trapping him inside The Well of Souls
with Marion and about six to ten
thousand snakes although Harrison Ford
wasn't actually afraid of snakes in real
life his co-star Karen Allen and
definitely was she was so terrified that
at one point Spielberg asked animal
Handler Steve Edge to shave his legs and
Dawn a dress to stand in for Allen using
a giant snake statue Indy busts a hole
in the wall breaking through to another
chamber filled with the decomposing
bodies of hundreds of dead adventurers
the two Escape Evolution to Brick in the
Wall only to find a Nazi Airfield
preparing to fly the ark out of Egypt
the airplane that Indie tussles around
was created specifically for Raiders by
production designer Norman Reynolds and
artist Ryan Cobb the two used
inspiration for the bv38's lying Wing
based on a mashup of various flying
wings from World War II including the
Horton ho 299 the Northrop n1m and the
vot v173 this plane was actually not
designed to fly and its only purpose was
to serve as a mechanism to kill Pat
roach again during the fight one of the
wheels of the plane ran over Ford's foot
but miraculously he wasn't injured
because the heat of the Tunisian Sun had
softened the tires because the majority
of the stunt actors were suffering from
dysentery when the scene was filmed
producer Frank Marshall sat in as the
pilot and like I said earlier this Burly
Nazi mechanic was Pat roach's second
role in Raiders Indy pursues the trucks
carrying the Ark on Horseback
interestingly this chase scene was
inspired by the 1939 film Stagecoach
which features a scene where John Wayne
aka the Ringo kid is on a stagecoach
attacked by Apache Cavalry Scouts in an
incredibly impressive feat for special
effects in the 1930s stunt performer
Yaki mckennette coordinated a single
take or one of the scouts leaps from his
horse onto the coach's team of horses
before being shot and dragged Beneath
The Carriage this is the moment that
inspired the decision to have Indie drag
me at the track in this scene as well a
few shots fired later in Stagecoach
Ringo kid has to make the leap from the
roof of the coach to the horse team
below which likewise inspired Indies
jump from the horse to the truck also
when this nasty ass hat flies through
the window of Gobbler's car you can hear
the quintessential long stream once the
arc is loaded safely aboard the [ __ ]
steamer headed for England marrying
kisses Sally goodbye afterwards he
begins singing another HMS pinafore tune
British tar but while Jones and Marion
make out in Captain katanga's private
quarters the ark has begun to burn a
hole in the swastika on the outside of
the box it's held in the scene where the
Nazi U-Boat captures the Bantu wind was
filmed on location in La Rochelle France
over at the intercom you can hear the
number eins eins dry act spoken in
German which translates to 1138 a
reference to thx-1138 another film
written and directed by George Lucas the
submarine in this scene was actually
borrowed from the set of 1981's Das Boot
which was also being shot in La Rochelle
at the time the Nazis steal the arc back
and after disembarking on an island in
the Aegean Sea begin the Trek with the
arcs through a very familiar looking
Canyon the city of bulau Canyon located
near the city of Tozer in Tunisia is
where Jones confronts the Nazis with a
rocket launcher this is the very same
place where they filmed several scenes
on tattooing and A New Hope while
filming this scene a fly landed on Paul
Freeman's lip while he delivered his
lines but he kept acting straight
through it because it was too hot
outside to keep pausing although it
appears that Bellic actually swallows
the fly Freeman insists that the fly's
departure from his face was left on The
Cutting Room floor Dr Jones can't bring
himself to blow up the ark due to its
historical significance so he and Marion
are captured and tied to a pole at the
center of the action while bellick
Dietrich taught and the other Nazis
prepare for the ritual that they believe
would connect them directly to God
inside the ark all that remained of the
Ten Commandments was a pile of sand and
the Nazis felt a brief moment of
disappointment Hitler was going to be
big mad but moments later the lighting
and electrical equipment surrounding the
site began to malfunction as soon as
Indy notices he instructs Marion to shut
her eyes because whatever is about to
come out of there cannot be good my
guess is that Jones remembered the Bible
verse first Samuel 6 19 but God struck
down some of the inhabitants of Beth
shamesh putting 70 of them to death
because they looked into the Ark of the
Lord making direct eye contact with this
artifact is a big No-No unless you want
your face melted off by the wrath of
Yahweh on set Freeman was directed to
act as if something was coming towards
and when the ark finally opened and to
scream for his life for the ghostly
special effects in this scene a
lucasfilm receptionist was suspended
midair against a blue screen in a white
robe to shoot the close-ups of the
spirits the bolts of lightning that
shoot from bellic's eyes match the
drawing of the arc that Jones showed the
two agents at the beginning of the movie
to avoid getting an R rating when
bellic's head explodes filmmakers had to
add a wall of fire to slightly obscure
his face and Top's face melt was filmed
by creating a model of the actor's head
and deflating it of course our heroes
don't suffer these horrific Fates
because they had the good sense not to
mess with an ancient Supernatural and
historic artifact there's a reason that
there's a lot of do not touch signs in
museums and this is definitely the main
one after Indian Marion survived the
Flames of the wrath of God we jump to an
establishing shot of 1930s Washington DC
that was actually footage taken from the
1975 movie The Hindenburg although Jones
is paid handsomely for recovering The
Arc intact and thwarting the Nazis the
US government does not heed his pleas to
display it in a museum we find out
shortly after that the ark is stored in
a crowded Warehouse surrounded by
hundreds and hundreds of other artifacts
this is an homage to the ending of
Citizen Kane where Charles Foster Kane's
childhood sled Rosebud is discarded in a
furnace with other items in Indiana
Jones and the kingdom of the Crystal
Skull we find out that this Warehouse is
actually part of area 51. after seeing a
cut of the movie Marsha Lucas George's
ex-wife pointed out that this ending
left viewers with no closure between
Indy and Marion which prompted Spielberg
to shoot this final scene showing them
together on the steps of City Hall
although they're supposed to be in
Washington the exterior was shot on the
steps of San Francisco City Hall Marcia
also worked as an editor for American
Graffiti and A New Hope along with other
films and was also the person to suggest
that Lucas kill Obi-Wan off in his
script making him Luke's Mentor instead
of allowing him to survive episode 4. so
we have a lot of nerdy ideas to thank
her for these are all the Easter eggs
that I could find in Raiders of the Lost
Ark but let me know if you guys find any
more in the comments follow me on
Instagram and Twitter at whitneypuppy
follow new Rockstar subscribe to your
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love and thanks for
watching bye
[Music]